welcome to this game I'm playing this I
am again from Belgium it's really a bit
much okay I'm trying Eve force white
let's see what he's doing playing the
haven in 97 thats that's an uncommon
line I'm not a not a bad choice against
someone like me you does not really know
the opens are so into well I think this
is right but not not really an expert I
came maybe Here I am protecting me five
Queen B 6 I have King edge one okay
going to e4 I guess maybe 95 for the
move
okay well here I'm going to go to g5 I
mean going backwards cannot be an idea
and h6 while I'm going to sacrifice on
f7 and f5 if he plays h6 there's always
those those checks on c5 and b6 that can
be terribly annoying I need to play King
edge one badly there are also ideas like
90 FOIA taking the night so that i can
sacrifice only six but there is always
this Bishop between b6 check Bishop c5
check yeah this kind of stuff yeah oh
okay there is there is no way back here
not sure at all if it makes any sense
but it looks dangerous really at least
our the first impression what exactly am
i threatening I'm threatening to take it
only six and then 95 and now i have e 6
getting something back but before i do
that let's check in the alternatives
night g fire for example this is an
alternative 6 kyndra and my g5 here yeah
but ok now if I can also just move the
King away so yeah I probably should do
that still no I mean after the capture
there is night h4 okay let's do this
first and then think about the detailed
consequences night h4 but he's got
rookie ahm and and this check
so probably I need to develop first
ruki aid is a big problem
yeah the development is really a really
an issue
yeah he can go there it's not it's not
really convincing all this please done
yeah there's always this F to business
as this looks like a very meek move here
but
yeah maybe I shouldn't have taken on
this seven I don't know and tough very
tough to play a 93 now coming or what
probably
let's do you can take it on or just LED
g5 I know against is checking out or
which I overlooked really
yeah there's no more freely that's
rookie one coming and this also you can
also just play g5 but didn't have any
move now that's enough white resides mmm
yeah five very very tough
Jack challenger it just seems to be good
for like what can you do a compass
giving it as good for black all the way
it looked interesting but here i don't i
don't really have anything else i need
to take it and he's just very quick with
King age seven so this is not not really
great
yeah absolutely nothing that I could
have done yeah really nothing I was just
looking at the the compy votes because
it's just it's it's a totally technical
position so it's just a question wonder
what the compass is calculating age
three here interesting now this was the
idea all along chant if it's not working
it's not working yeah that's it alright
thanks for watching